C'est quoi ça ?
Attend, mais c’est une météorite.
Mais c’était clairement une météorite, venez voir, elle a pété la vitre carrément.
C’est pas plutôt toi qui vient de péter la vitre là.
Parce qu’on vient de l’entendre et puis tu as du verre partout.
Tu fais quoi avec un œuf de Yoni toi ?
Un quoi ?
Faudrait quand même réparer la vitre là-haut, parce que je me caille, l’air, il passe sous ma porte.
On a déjà du mal à payer le loyer,
je suis pas sûr que ce soit notre priorité en fait.
On a qu’à vendre la météorite.
On ne peut pas vendre une météorite comme ça !
On vend la météorite, mais on dit que c’est une pierre magique.
Allez, moi j’vais faire l’annonce sur Le bon coin.
Mais c’est un mensonge !
Tout le monde a déjà utilisé ou au moins entendu l'expression « publicité mensongère ».
De manière générale, on considère que de la publicité mensongère c'est quand une marque communique
des choses fausses sur son produit pour nous induire en erreur.
L’exemple le plus connu, c’est de dire que les hamburgers de fast-food sont super beaux sur l’affiche et tout… et dégueu et moche une fois servi.
Mais la publicité mensongère qu'est-ce que c'est précisément ? Qui fait ça ?
Pourquoi ? Qu'est-ce qu'on peut y faire ? Tant de questions.
Déjà ça englobe beaucoup de choses, parce que ça désigne la communication sous toutes ses formes
visant à vendre quelque chose, donc tous les spots de pub, les affiches, etc.
Mais aussi un vendeur, car il peut vous induire en erreur volontairement
en vous présentant un produit de manière fausse.
Ensuite, il faut distinguer la publicité mensongère et la publicité trompeuse.
Par exemple, étiqueter une boisson contenant des additifs par la formule « pur jus de fruits».
La publicité trompeuse c'est en fait le cas le plus courant, et le plus complexe.
On considère qu'une publicité est trompeuse lorsque les éléments sont exacts mais que leur présentation laisse croire à des qualités inexistantes.
On peut être trompeur par omission aussi,
en oubliant d'intégrer dans sa communication des informations qui sont considérées comme importantes pour le consommateur.
Par exemple sur un site de commande d'objets en ligne,
vous pouvez voir une photo de ce genre avec le nom d’article « télévision » au prix de 5 €.
Là vous la commandez, mais il s'avère qu'en effet, c'était une fausse télévision miniature !
Bien sûr, il faut faire la différence avec les publicités exagérées par leur caractère créatif
et volontairement excessif, qui ne constituent bien sûr pas une infraction.
En gros, on doit savoir déterminer si la publicité consiste à induire délibérément le consommateur en erreur,
et c’est là que c’est compliqué.
Parce que le mensonge peut être volontaire mais aussi maladroit, ou simplement une imprécision causée par un manque de vigilance.
On peut également parler de publicité déloyale ou plus précisément de concurrence déloyale.
C’est quand, par exemple, une marque d'aspirateur qui va se présenter comme « la plus efficace du marché »
et prendre des parts de marché grâce ce message.
Là une marque concurrente d'aspirateur va pouvoir la poursuivre en disant :
il n'y a rien qui prouve que leur aspirateur est plus efficace que le nôtre, ils ne peuvent pas dire ça.
En bref, la publicité mensongère ça désigne beaucoup de choses et seulement certains cas sont punis par la loi,
et à différents niveaux selon les cas.
On va donc commencer par savoir lesquels,
quels sont les moyens pour le consommateur de réagir à ça, et quelles sont les peines encourues pour les marques.
Tu vois en droit, on n’est pas toujours sur un pied d’égalité.
En fait, il y a des situations où tu en as un qui a forcément l’ascendant sur l’autre.
Un salarié, par exemple, avec son employeur, il y a un rapport de force qui se crée.
Et c’est un peu pareil pour le consommateur.
On va considérer que c’est la partie faible au contrat.
C’est comme ça qu’on dit en droit.
Et du coup, on va essayer de le protéger au maximum.
On a même un code de la consommation qui a été fait
pour vraiment protéger ce consommateur.
Tu as par exemple les contrats d’adhésion où tu ne vas pas du tout pouvoir négocier.
Soit tu acceptes, soit tu vas chez le concurrent.
Mais tu ne vas pas du tout pouvoir négocier le prix ou ce genre de choses.
Par exemple, un opérateur téléphonique,
tu ne vas pas commencer à lui dire :
« vous pouvez me faire moins cher » ou ce genre de choses.
C’est pour ça qu’on va essayer de protéger le consommateur au maximum.
Du coup, la pratique commerciale trompeuse, on va soit essayer de donner des informations qui sont fausses,
soit qui sont parcellaires
pour essayer de jouer sur le consentement du consommateur,
et du coup de le tromper.
On appelle ça vicier son consentement en droit.
Et c’est pour ça que des fois, il y a des
assos de consommateur qui vont se constituer avec
des personnes qui ont été victimes qui vont faire ce qu’on appelle des actions de groupe.
Et ça, ce n’était pas toujours possible, c’est possible depuis 2014.
Aux États-Unis, franchement, on a vraiment l’habitude de ça,
mais en France, c’est assez nouveau.
C’est dans l’actualité en fait, parce que tu vois bien que le consommateur ne va pas forcément agir
contre un opérateur téléphonique tout seul,
alors que s’ils sont 100 ou 1000
à avoir eu le même problème,
ils auront vraiment une force de frappe.
A l'époque, c'était beaucoup moins surveillé, que ce soit par les consommateurs, ou même par la loi.
Après tout, dans les années 50 aux Etats-Unis, on utilisait la figure d'autorité du médecin
pour communiquer que les cigarettes n'étaient pas mauvaises pour la santé.
On dit souvent que le petit déjeuner est le repas le plus important de la journée.
Et cela viendrait de la diététicienne Lenna F. Cooper, qui aurait l'aurait écrit en 1917 dans le magazine Good Health,
magazine appartenant au docteur et nutritionniste John Harvey Kellogg,
connu surtout pour avoir inventé les célèbres cornflakes,
commercialisé par son frère à partir de 1907.
Cent ans plus tard, beaucoup d'études ont été menées depuis et aucune n'a pu trouvé une seule preuve
soutenant l'idée que la consommation d'un petit déjeuner promeut la perte de poids,
ça pourrait même avoir plutôt l'effet inverse.
Aujourd'hui, la loi est beaucoup plus vigilante et les consommateurs ont des outils pour se faire entendre.
Avec les réseaux sociaux, un « bad buzz » est vite arrivé.
Les réseaux sociaux ont fait évoluer le rapport entre les marques et les consommateurs en une relation verticale,
où la marque est au dessus et le consommateur en dessous,
vers une relation horizontale, où ils sont sur le même pied d'égalité.
D'où la grande tendance de la « transparence des marques » apparues dans les années 2010.
Parce qu'un seul consommateur avec le bon post au bon moment peut détruire l'image d'une marque.
Une erreur peut simplement venir d'un seul employé de la marque, indépendamment de cette dernière.
Comme lorsqu'un livreur de Domino's a été surpris en train de cracher sur une pizza avant de la donner à un client.
La vidéo avait évidemment tourné et indigné sur les réseaux sociaux.
Pour comprendre ça, il est important de savoir que pour une marque il y a l'identité de marque et l'image de marque, et ça n'est pas la même chose.
L'identité de marque est comment la marque souhaite apparaître selon la stratégie qui a été établi en interne.
Tandis que l'image de marque, c'est l'image réelle perçue naturellement par le public.
La publicité, elle va justement servir à influencer l'image de marque
qu'ont en tête les gens
pour qu'elle ressemble le plus possible à l'identité de marque prévue.
Mais du coup, faire de la publicité mensongère, c'est sûrement la pire chose à faire pour ça,
parce que même si sur le court terme, dire que son produit est plus incroyable qu'il ne l'est fera beaucoup plus de ventes,
sur le long terme, l'image de marque sera déplorable.
Les marques qui pèsent le plus sur le marché et qui sont installés depuis des décennies
n'essaient pas seulement de gagner constamment de nouveaux clients,
ils essaient surtout de garder les clients déjà acquis sur le long terme,
et pour ça il faut s'assurer de ne pas créer la déception entre ce qui est communiqué au consommateur et
l'expérience finale qu'il aura avec la marque.
Il y a donc 0 intérêt et 1.000 inconvénients pour une grande marque de faire de la publicité mensongère,
mais ce n'est pas toujours évident à éviter.
Vous avez peut-être déjà entendu l'histoire des consommateurs américains qui se plaignaient que RedBull ne donne pas réellement des ailes.
Alors on trouve ça rigolo et exagéré comme situation parce qu'on se dit
qu'ils sont bêtes, parce que c'est une façon de parler évidemment.
Mais ça c'est juste la manière dont ça a été médiatisé.
En réalité, la plainte accusait la marque de publicité mensongère
quand elle affirme que sa boisson augmente les performances,
la concentration et la réactivité,
tout en faisant payer la boisson plus cher pour cette raison,
alors qu’aucun étude scientifique ne prouve que Redbull apporte plus de bienfaits qu’une tasse de café.
Bien que Redbull  ait nié de son côté toute intention de nuire et affirmé que son marketing remplissait tous les critères définis par la loi,
ils ont finalement trouvé un accord avec les plaignants pour éviter de faire plus de bruit
et de créer la confusion avec un procès qui serait médiatisé et mauvais pour l'image de la marque.
Ils ont accepté de distribuer 13.000.000 de dollars entre les consommateurs,
chaque américain s'étant senti « déçu de la promesse de Redbull » entre 2002 et 2014
pouvait alors demander 10 dollars de dédommagement.
Et en 2019, un canadien qui trouvait ça injuste que seuls les américains aient été remboursé,
a attaqué Redbull pour les mêmes raisons,
et Redbull a du payer une deuxième fois,
cette fois pour les Canadiens et pour une période couvrant 2007 à 2019.
Et on pourrait le faire ici ici, oui.
Vous l'aurez compris, en tant que grosse marque il ne vaut mieux pas jouer avec les consommateurs.
Du coup, à qui ça pourrait profiter de faire de la publicité mensongère, trompeuse ou déloyale ?
Qui peut vouloir le faire délibérément ?
N'importe quelle nouvelle marque inconnue qui cherche à faire énormément de profit très vite avant de disparaître tout aussi vite.
La publicité mensongère peut servir un intérêt financier à court terme.
C'est la stratégie de beaucoup d'e-commerce, tous ces trucs dont vous voyez des pubs sur Instagram ou Facebook, et qui repose souvent sur du dropshipping.
En soi, le dropshipping, c'est pas illégal.
Pour rappel ou pour ceux qui ne le savent pas : ça consiste à choisir un produit sur un site de vente pas cher,
lui créer un nom et un marketing fort pour le vendre plus cher et empocher la marge de la vente.
En gros, il peut présenter une montre comme une montre de luxe,
indiquer au client qu'il peut l'avoir au prix exceptionnel de 79€ au lieu du prix barré 429€
dans une période limitée de temps,
alors qu'à la base le vendeur aura sélectionné une montre qui coûte 9€ sur un site de vente pas cher.
Mais ce n'est pas tout, parce que les gens qui commandent sur le beau site le produit plus cher,
activent automatiquement une commande sur le site de vente pas cher,
et du coup il n'y a aucun stock à gérer.
C'est super simple, et en gros ils investissent juste dans de la publicité sur les réseaux sociaux.
Le dropshipping peut être certes mal vu, mais en vrai c'est juste du commerce,
ce n'est pas du tout illégal.
Par contre mentir sur les 4P de son mix marketing : soit product, price, place, promotion, ça c'est illégal.
C'est pour ça qu'après avoir fait massivement beaucoup de ventes,
ils suppriment souvent tout sans laisser de traces
et sans même vérifier que les acheteurs ont reçu leur colis
et refont un nouveau business autre part avec un nouveau produit et un nouveau branding.
Et en fait le dropshipping c'est similaire sur plein de points au télé-achat à la télévision !
Au télé-achat c'était souvent des produits achetés en grosse quantité pas cher, rebrandé avec un nom différent,
dont les mérites du produit étaient beaucoup trop exagérés,
et qui le vendait à prix barré dans une période limitée de temps.
Le télé-achat c'était un peu du dropshipping avant l'heure.
Et tant qu’on remonte dans le temps,
vous vous souvenez des bracelets Power Balance ?
C’est ces trucs-là,
on disait que c’était des bracelets dits « énergétiques ».
D'après ses fabricants, le produit utilisait une technologie holographique exclusive
basée sur une philosophie orientale
et servant à apporter un bienfait sur l'énergie naturelle du corps,
sur notre force, notre souplesse et notre équilibre.
C'est un produit qui est rapidement devenu viral,
notamment grâce au placement de produit chez des célébrités,
qui le positionnait comme un accessoire de mode.
Le bracelet Power Balance a été vendu à plusieurs millions d’exemplaires à travers les Etats-Unis et plus de 40 pays.
Cependant, aucune méthode scientifique ne permettait de prouver les effets prétendus du bracelet.
C'est pourquoi en 2010, le bracelet a commencé à faire polémique
et de nombreuses plaintes ont fait surface
dans le monde entier.
La répression des fraudes australienne a contraint la société à reconnaître qu'elle faisait de la publicité mensongère,
et à payer plusieurs millions de dollars.
Après ce jugement, Power Balance Belgique s'est présentée comme indépendante de Power Balance USA,
et a continué à vendre ses produits et c’est toujours le cas actuellement.
Mais pourquoi, comment, qu’est-ce qui se passe ?
Si Power Balance se vend toujours actuellement en Belgique, c'est parce que le marketing est très différent,
ils n'inventent pas des bienfaits.
Le bracelet est présenté avant tout comme un objet esthétique et ciblant les sportifs,
sans argument particulier.
Ce n'est donc pas de la publicité mensongère.
C'est un peu le même débat avec la lithothérapie par exemple.
Alors si vous savez pas, la lithothérapie, c'est une discipline qui consiste à se soigner
grâce à des cristaux, comme l'améthyste, la citrine, l'aigue-marine, le rubis, le turquoise, et consors.
Les promoteurs de la lithothérapie expliquent que les cristaux émettent naturellement une « résonance »
qui serait capable d'améliorer le bien-être d'une personne s'ils sont proches d'elles.
Un cristal agirait selon son type sur la « fréquence vibratoire » de certains points du corps.
Ces pierres se portent en pendentif, en collier ou en bracelet, mais elles peuvent aussi être disposées dans une pièce.
Plus le coût de la pierre est élevé, plus la pierre aurait de grandes capacités,
et les pierres peu chères auraient des capacités moins grandes,
Comme par hasard.
Du coup, si la valeur d'achat influence directement les pouvoirs des cristaux,
ça me semble important de savoir si c'est vérifiable ces fameux pouvoirs ?
Alors ça n’a pas été vérifié en tout cas, l’énergie des pierres.
Il y a bien une étude en 2001, ils ont tenté avec 80 volontaires, je crois.
Ils leur ont foutu un cristal de quartz dans la main
et ils ont envoyé tout le monde aller méditer pendant 10 minutes et puis noter après leurs sensations.
Les gens ont tous quasiment trouvé une sensation de chaleur dans la main au niveau du cristal
et un bien-être général.
Ils étaient 72 sur 80 à noter ce genre de sensation.
Et plot twist, c’est que la moitié des cristaux en question, c’était des fakes,
c’était juste du plastique.
Ce qui montre que c’est jusque l’effet contextuel, tout ce qui est placebo et compagnie,
qui aurait joué là-dedans en tout cas.
À ce jour, il n’y a pas de preuve scientifique de l’efficacité de la lithothérapie.
Ce qu’ils mettent en avant en général, c’est vraiment le côté
que les pierres pourraient émettre une forme d’énergie et à ce jour, la seule forme d’énergie qu’on ait trouvé, c’est la radioactivité
qui émane de certaines pierres, genre l’uranite qui est un minerai d’uranium.
Dans ce genre de cas, je te déconseille si tu en as chez toi de te le mettre autour du cou.
Du coup, aucune preuve scientifique pour l'efficacité de la thérapie,
ou même pour l'existence d'une énergie spécifique à ces cristaux.
Pourtant, certains ouvrages influents présentent la lithothérapie de façon beaucoup trop surestimée,
ce qui a forcément une influence sur le marché de ces cristaux.
Dans « le guide pratique de la lithothérapie » que l'on peut trouver dans plusieurs grandes enseignes au rayon « bien-être »,
on peut y découvrir des cristaux servant à traiter le sida.
C'est évidemment faux, la lithothérapie ne pouvant soigner aucune réelle maladie, quelle qu'elle soit comme on vient de le dire.
Du coup, là c'est un problème,
que les associations de lutte contre le sida n'ont pas du tout apprécié d'ailleurs.
Un site de vente en ligne qui vendrait des pierres et qui aurait ce genre de discours pour les vendre aurait de gros soucis,
vendre les pierres en promettant un bienfait non fondé est de la publicité mensongère.
Ce n'est cependant pas un souci si ceux qui vendent les pierres ne promettent rien sur leurs bienfaits, et vendent juste des pierres,
ça n'est pas de la publicité mensongère et ils ne sont pas responsables de ce qui est dit dans certains ouvrages,
même s'ils peuvent vendre ces mêmes ouvrages aussi sur leur site.
Vous suivez ?
Puis même si on souhaite en parler dans sa boutique,
promettre au conditionnel qu' « on dit que ça rendrait plus en forme »,
n'est pas la même chose que dire « arrêtez votre traitement contre le cancer pour vous soigner uniquement avec des pierres »
En vrai, si une personne dort mal et se sent aidée par la sois-disante énergie que va lui apporter une pierre,
même si c'est basé sur un effet contextuel et placebo,
tant que cette personne ne met pas tout son argent là-dedans,
et qu'il l'achète sur un site qui vend juste des pierres sans rien promettre,
tout va bien dans ce cas là.
Suivant ce qui est communiqué avant l'acte d'achat au consommateur, cela peut donc être légal ou illégal.
Maintenant, à partir de tout ce qu'on a appris on va faire une annonce pour notre météorite
afin de la vendre et de gagner de l'argent.
Et pour ça on va donc découvrir un autre type de publicité mensongère,
l'arnaque entre particuliers, sur les sites d'annonces.
Il faut qu'on fasse une annonce, en mentant pour être sûr de la vendre très vite,
tout en restant dans la légalité pour ne pas avoir de problèmes.
Pour ça on va utiliser l'art du copywriting.
Le copywriting, c’est l’art de séduire et de persuader avec les mots,
il a été inventé par les plus grands publicitaires durant les années 50 et...
Bois un coup, bois un coup.
Parce que t’allais en dire des conneries. Tu ne me remercieras pas de t’avoir interrompu hein.
Vous les marketeux, qu’est-ce que vous feriez pas vous pour vendre vos tapis. C’est un truc de ouf, non ?
Bah j’étais juste en train de...
Ouais, c’est ça, fais la carte du déni…
“c’est pas moi, c’est vous, vous alliez faire une bonne affaire” allez dégage.
Dégage.
Laisse faire les gens qui ont des compétences.
Ça va bien hein.
Le copywriting, une technique pour persuader avec les mots,
inventée par les grands marketeux des années 50…
non mais qu’est-ce qu’il faut pas entendre quand même…
Parce que persuader par les mots, c’est vieux comme le monde, et ça s’appelle la rhétorique.
En fait, plus précisément, le mot rhétorique vient du grec ancien ῥητορικὴ τέχνη/rhêtorikê tekhnê, signifiant “technique oratoire”,
d’où le mot rhéteur en français pour désigner ceux qui sont bons en discours.
Aristote a beaucoup écrit dessus.
La rhétorique, en fonction de qui la pratique, vise deux fonctions,
celle de bien parler, c’est l’éloquence,
et celle de bien convaincre, c’est la persuasion.
Les deux sont presque toujours liées, et dans l’Antiquité, on associait alors la rhétorique à la politique et à la justice.
Des personnages comme Aristote et Anaximène chez les Grecs,
ou comme Quintilien et Cicéron chez les Romains, ont beaucoup écrit sur cette pratique langagière.
Si on suit le dogme des sophistes, qui sont des orateurs et professeurs de rhétoriques de la Grèce Antique,
parler ne sert pas à expliquer mais à convaincre.
Pardon, je m’étouffe avec ma salive.
Ainsi, ils étudient et élaborent des stratégies pour séduire un auditoire avec les mots,
mettant le but de persuasion au-dessus de celle de dire la vérité.
Du copywriting… non mais l’autre ! Du copywriting, sans déconner.
Dans le domaine de la publicité, on peut remarquer quelques constructions qui, en français, permettent de viser cet effet de conviction sans jamais totalement trahir la vérité.
La clé, c’est d’utiliser à outrance de modalité,
c’est-à-dire d’éléments qui permettent d’injecter du subjectif dans un énoncé,
pour connaitre notamment le rapport de l’interlocteur par rapport à ce qu’il énnonce.
C’est une définition très large, mais regardez par exemple la phrase suivante :
j’aime les chats.
Désormais, prenez celle-ci :
bien sûr, j’aime les chats.
Dans la seconde, bien sûr est un modalisateur,
il apporte une information ou un jugement sur la seconde partie de l’énoncé.
Evidemment que j’aime les chats, pas vous ?
Dans le cadre de la publicité, on va utiliser deux types de constructions modales.
Des verbes au conditionnel plutôt qu’à l’indicatif,
car le conditionnel permet de sortir du cadre de la réalité ou de la vérité,
il est alors plus facile d’émettre une hypothèse, un jugement,
injecter de la subjectivité dans le propos :
il aimerait les chats.
On peut même faire usage de semi-auxiliaires modaux, comme devoir ou pouvoir,
qui utilisés comme tels apportent une dose d’incertitude en plus.
il devrait aimer les chats.
Et puis, il y a les adverbes modaux, les constructions adverbiales en général, tout simplement.
Selon les informations que j’ai pu trouvées, il devrait aimer les chats.
On peut aussi substituer les conditionnels avec les adverbes comme “probablement, peut-être, sans doute”.
Il aime probablement les chats. C’est ce que j’ai cru entendre. En tout cas, c’est fort possible.
Sait-on jamais.
Ca s’trouve, la personne dont on parle déteste les chats.
Mais il nous en coûte rien de formuler ces énoncés, nous n’énonçons aucune vérité.
Bon, alors,
On va jouer sur la beauté de la pierre avec un visuel
retouché aux niveaux des couleurs, pour qu'elles ressortent.
Pour montrer qu'on est sur du luxe on va mettre un prix qui semble cher pour ce que c'est.
Mais pour le justifier, on va créer le mystère avec le nom de l'annonce qui est
« pierre inconnue » qui est neutre et donc pas un mensonge.
Ensuite, on va se dédouaner en expliquant que la pierre vient de quelqu'un d'autre,
et ça, ça va permettre de créer du storytelling.
Après, on va placer une figure d'autorité pour convaincre grâce au spécialiste,
mais qui n'a en réalité parler qu'à votre ami, sur qui vous vous dédouaner.
On va expliquer que ce prix qui semble énorme, est en fait seulement un quart de sa vraie valeur,
pour donner l'impression de faire une bonne affaire.
Après tout ça, on va se justifier pour diminuer la méfiance avec un prétexte un peu vague.
En rappelant à celui qu'il lit qu'il est vraiment malin s'il saisit l'occasion, qu'il va forcément faire une bonne affaire.
Et la petite touche, on crée un second compte et on propose une offre à 160€
pour faire croire qu'il y a d'autres gens déjà intéressés.
Ainsi on croira que la demande est supérieure à l'offre et ça créera un sentiment d'urgence.
Alors, regardez,
Pierre inconnue. 200 euros.
Un ami a trouvé cette pierre dans son jardin,
selon un spécialiste qu'il connaît,
il s'agirait d'un cristal précieux aux vertus médicinales,
pouvant valoir jusqu'à 800 €, vu son poids.
Je n'ai pas le temps de la faire expertiser, c'est pourquoi je vous la laisse pour 200 €,
soit un quart de son prix estimé.
A saisir !!!!!
Et ça, ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça, ça veut dire qu’il l’a déjà vendue.
Eh oui. Ca marche bien le marketing.
J’suis un génie.
Merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo, si elle vous a plu,
vous pouvez mettre un pouce en l’air, la partager,
commenter, vous abonner, mettre la cloche, et puis si vous avez envie d’en parler d’avantage,
vous pouvez nous joindre sur le Discord du Vortex.
Et si vous voulez qu'on continue à parter de publicités mensongères,
venez, je suis au moment de la sortie de cette vidéo en live sur ma chaine Twitch,
le lien s'affiche ici, ou il est dans la description.
Et venez, on va s'amuser, c'est la pure vérité.